I keep tweeting about the workflow I'm
about to show you, and every single time
I do, the tweet goes viral. Why? Because
it unlocks the missing 90% of Claude
Code's incredible design capabilities.
If you're using Claude Code, Cursor, or
any other coding agent for front-end
development, you need to hear this. If
you're anything like I used to be, you
prompt for a greatl looking modern
design just to end up with the same
generic shad CN purple UI that you see
all over Twitter. Getting pixel perfect
refinements feels impossible and like
you're just going around in circles
trying to convince the model to please
just do what you asked it. I hate to
break it to you, but those cookie cutter
designs aren't the model's fault. It's
the environment that you're placing
those agents in. You're taking an
incredible PhD level intelligence and
you're forcing it to design with
essentially blindfolds on the models.
They can't see their own designs. They
can only see the code that they're
writing. Or in other words, they're only
using the text side of their modality,
not the vision side. What I'm about to
show you is a massive unlock our team
has found. It's a single tool that gives
the AI eyes to see. the missing link in
a workflow. All built around the
Playright MCP, allowing these agents to
control the browser, take screenshots,
iteratively self-correct on their
designs, and to do so much more. I'll
take you through my exact workflows that
will give you design superpowers,
including the setup for sub
agents/comands,
the Playright MCP config details, and
also how I've customized my claw.md
file. In addition to some other hard one
insights, I will also sneak in some of
the most powerful mental models and
tactics that we've discovered for
getting the most out of cloud code along
the way. Feel free to reference the
descriptions timestamps to skip around
to what's most relevant to you. By the
way, I'm Patrick, the CTO and co-founder
of an AI native startup who's been using
Cloud Code heavily since it was first
released back in February. This workflow
is the single biggest front-end unlock
that we found. We have the honor of
working with the world's largest brands
including Google, Coca-Cola, Disney,
Nike, Microsoft, and others who expect
worldclass designs. So, we're constantly
looking for ways to get any edge that we
can. And I hope you can benefit from
these workflows, too. So, with that,
let's dive in. Playright is a framework
developed by Microsoft that is actually
more for web testing and automation
allowing you to navigate around the
browser and take screenshots and do
different endto-end tests. But what's
really really powerful for our purposes
is the MCP that they've released. So
I'll go ahead and show you the Playright
GitHub page. As you can see, we've got
over almost 76,000 stars at the time of
this recording. They highlight Chromium,
WebKit, and Firefox as different
browsers that you have access to. But if
I navigate over to the
Microsoftplayright-m
repository, we've got a bunch of readme
items, including quick start guide here
for Cloud Code and other agents. As you
can see, it is really easy to add
Playright to Cloud Code, but I will
revisit this in a second to give you a
few more configuration details that you
want to include. Now that you know a
little bit more about playright, I want
to introduce you to the key concept that
I keep coming back to as I add new tools
and in this case for a design workflow
and that is this orchestration layer.
See what we want to do is we want to put
claw code in a framework to give it a
foundation where it's able to have all
the context it needs all the tools to go
out and take actions or get additional
context and then clear validation state
examples of good and bad outcomes style
guides or anything else that can give it
a definitive example of what is needed
in terms of output. So if you have the
validation such as a UI mock or a style
guide, you have the tools such as of
course playright in this case and you
have the context well-written prompts
and documentation you will get so much
more success out of claude code than it
comes just out of the box. So in this
case we are focusing mostly on the
playright tool and also the validation
step which is baked into some of my sub
aent workflows. The second key insight
that really brings the 10x and the 10x
design flow is this idea of an iterative
agentic loop. Imagine as we get more and
more capable models, what we want to do
is we want to give them access to more
and more of our workflow so that they
can not just run for five minutes, but
they could run for half an hour or an
hour or even longer than that. The huge
unlocks that we get in productivity come
from this iteration loop that allow
these agents to not just run for longer
as I mentioned but also to come to much
better outputs. We need a fixed spec or
validator in order to iterate against so
that we can compare the output that cla
code gets again and again until we get
exactly the output that we're expecting.
In this case, you can imagine claude
code first looks at a spec. So, a style
guide, a UI mock, whatever you're
providing in the prompt and some of
these other bits of context. And then
you allow it to go ahead and tool check
or look at the playwright screenshot in
our case and compare that iteratively to
what it's building and back to the spec.
So, if it's able to go out, make some
changes, take a screenshot, look at
that, and then identify, oh shoot, this
SVG is nowhere close to what the user
asked me, and then go back again. That
iterative loop is what really gets us to
these full agentic workflows and saves
us a ton of time because we can kick off
a process, go work on something else and
not have to babysit it and prompt five
different times in order to get to the
end result. You have that context built
in. And the final big conceptual piece
here is thinking about the training data
that is under cloud code, specifically
Opus 4.1 and Sonnet 4. What do they have
in their neural nets or what circuits do
they have in their minds when it comes
to good design? If you think about it,
this is just an estimation here, but the
common crawl and text makes up the
majority of the training data. So, this
is books, just general stuff on the
internet, but we also have code that
these foundation labs are training more
and more on. And then we have images and
the multimodal models. Multimodal
meaning, of course, you're bringing in
all kinds of different modalities,
including images and text in this case.
The thing is though, when we're
typically using cloud code, we're not
tapping into the images side or the
visual modality within cloud code.
Indirectly, we get a little bit of that
benefit, but we're really just looking
at code best practices and other design
principles, but we're not allowing the
model to use its intellect when it comes
to understanding and looking at visual
design. So, we're missing out on all
that intelligence in the model, all
those neurons, if you will, or circuits
that help the model parse visual bits.
And that's where being able to provide a
screenshot via the Playright MCP unlocks
all of that potential, which as you can
imagine, when you're looking at designs,
that is a huge, huge help versus not
being able to think about things from a
visual perspective, but more from an
abstract or coding best practices
perspective. So the playright MCP
getting all that additional visual
context unlocks a lot of intelligence as
well from cloud code. So if I go back
here, we can scroll down to a few of the
playright capacities that are most
helpful. The first is being able to
automatically capture screenshots. So
you can imagine allowing claude code to
open up pages that you're working on or
to automatically trigger that through a
cloudMD configuration sub agent or a
slash command that you can run which
I'll show you in a second here. This is
the most powerful piece because it
unlocks the vision modality within cloud
code and allows you to enhance its
ability to think critically through
designs and also to see pixel perfect
captures of different UI elements that
need to change.
The second one is being able to read
browser console logs. So having access
to both the browser console logs and the
network logs in order to basically view
them and automatically read and make
changes as needed.
We can also emulate different devices in
various browser sizes. So you're
essentially setting the Chrome or
whatever browser window when it
launches. And you can also emulate, for
example, an iOS device. You can navigate
around the browser. So you can click
around, enter form field data and cloud
code can automatically look at context
and make the next step. Okay, so that's
awesome. But what does it actually get
us in terms of workflows? These are the
best workflows that I found. The first
that is mostly the theme of this video
is being able to agentically iterate on
the front end using the screenshots and
the logs that it it gathers. And this is
the key to really producing much better
looking UIs. The second is automatically
being able to fix any obvious UI errors
or errors that are in the console. Then
you have the ability and this is really
cool to navigate the browser. You can
imagine if you have a user spec of I do
XYZ and I get an error or there's a
visual error when this state happens.
You can ask cloud code to navigate in
that same method. click buttons, enter
form field data, and navigate around in
order to reproduce a certain state and
then grab the console logs or any other
context that's needed in order to help
solve your issue. Another cool workflow
is being able to visually render and
screenshot or scrape different reference
URLs. So you can imagine if you put in a
URL or a couple of them that reference a
beautiful design or a website that you
would like some inspiration from, you
can include that in your prompt or spec
and then let playright go out navigate
that locally on your browser and take a
screenshot of those pages or get any
other context. And then you have the
original intent of playright which is
the automated end toend testing or any
accessibility audits being able to ask
it to go and look for any accessibility
issues. We have mobile responsive
testing which is really helpful even if
you just do a quick tablet, desktop and
mobile view port size or of course
emulating like an iOS device to just get
a quick gut check on if there are any
mobile responsive issues. One kind of
cool use case that I actually had cloud
code come up with on its own is being
able to scrape data. I was using
firecrawl to gather some data which is
another MCP from a few websites and it
got a 403 i.e. it was blocked on a
couple of them. So, it went ahead and
spun up a new Playright browser in order
to load that same web page and then
gather all the data on its own, which I
thought was pretty clever and just cool
to see these emergent properties. And on
that note, what's so cool is that these
MCPs can allow cloud code to do so much
more than just in the coding modality or
in how we typically think of, for
example, Playright. It really gives it
full access to your browser to be a full
browser-based agent. And you can imagine
from the data scraping idea to
automatically logging in and submitting
data or getting to a certain end state
in your app or just navigating a website
to do almost anything. This is a really
powerful unlock for cloud code. All
right, I'm going to show you a couple
key installation details that you may
want to consider when configuring
playright in addition to my sub agents
pod MD file customizations/comands
and a few other details that have been a
huge game changer for me. So with that
you can see we're able to configure
different browsers but this is done at
the MCP config level. So with some MPC
configurations you'll define it in a
JSON blob like this and you can see you
can just supply different arguments but
that could alternatively be the browser
that you want. So two I want to call out
are the browser that you're using also a
device if you want to emulate for
example the iPhone 15. And then another
one that's really interesting is being
able to run in headless or headed mode.
I usually run it just in the default
which is headed. So I can see it up and
and uh navigating the browser. You can
easily grab in the installation section
for cloud code just this one line here
in order to install the MCP. I can just
run this sample command. Uh in this case
I've already got playright installed of
course. So I'll go ahead and fire up
claude. Then now if I type for/mcp,
you can see that I've got it installed
here along with a couple other MCPS.
This is just my personal website uh for
demonstration purposes. So I don't have
I just have a couple MCP options here.
Here you can see exactly what
configuration it's using and arguments
that it's applying. And you can also
view the tools which show the many
different tools that it gives Cloud Code
access to. There is a vision mode for
playright which allows it to use
coordinate based operations instead of
the default which is the accessibility
map which is basically just a way to
navigate the different elements within a
website which is a lot faster and easier
but for some applications it can be
better to use vision mode. So that's
another argument you might want to
consider using. I know these config
files like a cursor rules or cloudmd can
sound pretty boring when you first think
about it. But in this case, if you watch
Enthropics different YouTube videos or
if you read through all their
documentation and guides, they really
think about these cloudm files as being
memory for the agents. So everything you
write here is basically put right after
the system prompt when you start up any
cloud code session. So any details that
you want to be brought into every single
session that you're using, shortcuts
that prevent cloud code from having to
go grip around and grab a bunch of
context or any best practice or rules
that you want it to follow like a style
guide or get styles. Uh so like how do
you want commits and branches and PR
structured all that should live in
something like this so that it's pulled
in automatically. And what that means is
just one less thing. It's essentially an
automation. one less thing that you have
to worry about every time you're using
cloud code that just abstracts it away
from your mind and it's also portable so
other people on your team can take that
exact same cloud config file and move it
around. So with that one of the biggest
lifts when it comes to playright in
terms of getting that agentic loop that
keeps moving is to add a configuration
down here that speaks to that. So I've
got this visual development section and
in there I've got a design principles
spot here. This basically just points
Claude to a few different documents that
I provided in this context folder. I'm a
big fan of doing this where I'll just
drop a bunch of context in this folder.
So, in my case, it's like uh for a
personal website summary of my LinkedIn
uh kind of my life story listed out a
bit, but also design principles and a
style guide that I want Claude Code to
follow. So, if I open up the design
principles file, you can see this is
just a long list of a bunch of different
principles I want Claude Code to follow.
In this case, I actually used Gemini
deep research on all the best design
principles for a specific aesthetic that
I like a lot. I had it make that into a
much more concise markdown file. Went
through, edited a few things, and then I
use that as my design principles MD
file. I do find that doing the deep
research approach for SEO best practices
or design best practices or back-end
architectural principles is an amazing
way to kickstart what you're working on,
especially if it's a little bit out of
your domain of expertise. An incredible
way to use just this massive amount of
knowledge and to make it actionable
going from collecting that knowledge in
a deep research platform into an
actionable thing that an agent like
Claude Code can take and run with. And
then if I go down here, this is where I
lay out specifically how I want Claude
Code to use the Playright browser on a
kind of a normal day-to-day level.
Whenever you're doing anything that
involves the front end, I want it to go
ahead and navigate to the pages that
were impacted by those front-end changes
and then reference this verification
step of the uh orchestration framework
by using these markdown documents and
then look for any acceptance criteria
that may have been laid out in the
prompt that I had written. So Cloud Code
can look and see what exactly I
supplied. So again, this could be a UI
mockup. This could be just some text and
other instructions that I gave it. A
Figma MCP. There's all kinds of
acceptance criteria that could have been
brought into the prompt. And then I want
it to just pull up the normal browser
size that I've got here for the desktop
viewport. You could also have this be a
mobile or tablet size or include all
three of them, but just for the sake of
time, I just wanted to quickly open up
the window and and look. And then of
course I also want to check for any
console errors because that's a huge
timesaver. In addition to that, I want
it to sometimes go into a comprehensive
design review. So this is where it will
use this sub agent that I created that
I'll mention in a second here in order
to go ahead and do a much deeper dive
than just this quick test that I showed
above. If I'm creating a PR, I want it
to go ahead and do that or any very
significant UIUX refactors and a few
other key details that I want it to
remember just to make sure that it
doesn't try to bring in any new
frameworks or libraries or anything. One
powerful trick I want to call out here,
this is a huge tip and I've learned so
much by doing this is being able to go
reference the examples that Enthropic
gives when it comes to how to configure
any sort of document, but especially
things like sub aents, the cloud MD
file, slashcomands, and actions that run
in GitHub, for example. So, the first
thing I just want to point out is their
GitHub. They've got a lot of great stuff
in here. some actual courses, uh the
cookbook, which is a lot of different
examples of interesting ways to use
claude, and then also the claude code
security review repo. It's a slash
command. So, just as a reminder,
whenever you type forward slash, it's
it's these commands that come up. And
I've got a few custom ones that I built
in accordance with this convention where
you have acloud folder and then in there
you've got a commands folder and then
you can create these markdown files. So,
what I'll do is I'll just look at what
is Anthropic doing? Like, how are they
structuring these commands or these sub
agents? And there's a lot of cool stuff
in here. For example, in this case, this
ability to basically just take your
working or work in progress files that
are not in a PR yet. So, this was a
great little workflow I borrowed and
just looking at how they structure
things, how they use capital, all caps
in certain cases. Overall, it's it's
great to learn from exactly how they're
building things. Another guide I would
highly recommend, I've recommended this
to so many people, is the cloud code
best practices for agentic coding guide.
This is does a great job especially for
things like claude MD of breaking down
exactly how to structure things and the
methodology behind it all. And then I
would also recommend the documentation.
It's very well put together. A lot of
great examples specifically for cloud
code here. All right, so with that I'll
go ahead and show you mycloud directory.
Then we've got an agents directory and a
commands directory. So in agents, you
can see I've got the design reviewer.
Just as a quick example, in order to
invoke this, I'll just do at@ agent
design review. I could give it like a PR
or more instructions like please review
the last three commits that I've made.
And that's going to go ahead and kick
off the agent design reviewer. You can
see here it's pretty intelligent. It's
going ahead and using Git to just grab
the last three commits and it's going to
go ahead and launch the agent in order
to follow the exact workflow that I laid
out there. So, while it's running, I'm
going to go ahead and show you that
workflow. So, I've got a name, the
description of what it's doing. You can
see it's a design review agent that is
able to look at pull requests or general
UI changes and then I give it specific
access to different tools. Uh so I'm
able to explicitly ask it to use just
basically playright context 7 which is
for documentation and really great MCP
as well and then also the built-in uh
tools that you typically give an agent.
I'm having it use sonnet for this kind
of work. I feel like I haven't noticed a
huge difference or any difference
between sonnet and opus and of course
sonnet's way cheaper. And then I just
give it this description of what I'm
asking it to do. So in this case I'm
channeling trying to get to the areas
within its its circuits or it's its
neural net that are to do with design
reviews and uh principal level
designers. So I'll usually give it
persona to try to channel that and then
a few examples. So stripe airb uh some
some cliche classics in Silicon Valley
and then I give it a core methodology
and mission to go on here for reviewing.
And then I give it a step-by-step guide
of uh exactly how to go about doing a
robust design review including looking
for accessibility, code health or
robustness. So you can see it goes
through each of these steps and then I
also give it a format for how exactly I
want the report to look and I just ask
it not to do much more than that. So you
can see um the structure here and then
also the exact uh process for navigating
like which tools to use and when. In
order to come up with this, I actually
used another deep research report. I had
it go out and basically collect the best
design review practices from essentially
all of the internet and had it all
filtered through Claude Opus in this
case to shape it up using the agent
creation tool in Claude code in addition
to referencing different examples that
Enthropic has put in their GitHub repos.
So, just to show that you can go and
open up by typing in agents,
and that will open this new window that
allows you to edit different agents or
create a new one. So, I'll start off by
just creating a new agent. I usually
just do the current project. I will
almost always do the generate with
Claude. I took the deep research
summary. I fed all that into here along
with like a paragraph descriptor of
exactly what I want the agent to do. And
then I let Claude's um built-in process
here go ahead and create the initial
draft of the agent and then I took that
draft which was just a markdown file in
the Claude agents directory. But then
what I did is I asked Claude code to go
ahead and take the documentation from
Anthropics website and to review and
edit the agent markdown file in
accordance to what the best practices
lay out and those examples of other ones
that I had to work with in order to
really get a concise greatlooking
document. So I did that exact flow for
the slash commands, the agent as I just
mentioned, and my uh cloud.md file. And
I feel like that really helps you get
concise, actionable workflows. By the
way, if you are finding value in this
YouTube video, it means a ton if you
would give it a like and subscribe if
you're interested in learning these new
AI native workflows. And as a thank you,
I will include in the description links
to all of these files so that you can
download them and reference them and use
them as you wish. All right, so let's go
ahead and look at our sub agent. Could
you please look at the homepage on my
website, the main page, and give me a
detailed review as outlined in the agent
review configuration?
So, as you can see, that wasn't the best
articulated prompt, but it's enough to
get the agent to go ahead and
proactively work. I've got here a window
that was opened up, so it's identifying
that we have the port in use. Okay,
great. So, it went ahead and loaded my
personal website. Here it is adjusting
the screen size and it's grabbing
screenshots in order to collect some UI
context that it can bring back to see
what it needs to fix. It's pretty
surreal watching these work and your
mind just starts to go a little wild
thinking of all the applications that
you could use for this to automate
different parts of your workflow. I'm
just thinking of all the time I spend
doing mobile responsive testing and also
the times I forget to do it in uh that
ends up in a bug where this can just
solve that because Claude can come back
to us with a fully baked version. So in
this case it's asking if it wants to go
ahead and try submitting the email
signup form that I have on my website.
So I'll go ahead and say yeah. You can
see it went ahead and typed in uh and
subscribe to my newsletter just to get a
sense of uh the context there for what
it looks like which is just fantastic.
Also, every time I click yes and don't
ask me again, it will uh save that into
my local file so that cloud code knows
it can just go ahead and do these
things. Another cool element with these
is you can have the sub aents call other
sub aents which is really helpful when
it comes to creating a network of almost
like conditional logic. So you could
have one design reviewer invoke like a
mobile designer for example and uh other
reviewers and then in aggregate all of
these have their own context and they
use their own uh models. You can specify
if it's sonnet or opus or or whatever
model you want to use and because of
that you don't cloud the main context of
your your main thread in cloud code. So
you can have a bunch of sub aents go do
a bunch of work and summarize and bring
back the executive report. for example,
a list of to-dos that need to be
changed, or in this case, a design
review report. If you look over here,
we've got the official report back from
the design review agent. And it's got
some uh some constructive feedback, an A
minus. I'll uh I'll take it. Uh I don't
claim to be an amazing designer. It's
got here a few strengths that it lists
out, some high priority issues to work
on, multiple image preload warnings
affecting performance. Okay, that's
helpful to know. Third party script air
from ptxcloud.net net and misconfigured
metatag more subjective things too like
newsletter iframe needs a better
integration is a great example of where
it's using the vision side of its neural
net now of course this is a really basic
example typically we're using this on
much more meaningful or like new
development you can imagine how getting
this feedback and then having the model
actually address the feedback creating
that iterative loop is really powerful
automatically addressing any errors or
issues is helpful but in this case what
I typically do is I would just invoke it
uh saying like hey could you please
address the above issues the you know
everything within high priority or maybe
I'd outline you know just a couple
specifics that I want here but you can
also chain these in different loops as I
mentioned before with the sub agents
that can call each other very powerful
way to iterate agentically and
automatically to a much better end
result than what you get on just a first
pull of cloud code one extra bonus I'll
throw in for you is this idea of git
work trees. So a big concept within
using cloud code that I found to be an
extremely big unlock is doing multiple
things in parallel. You can work on
different projects that don't interact
with each other. That's nice. But I
think another strategy that has been
really helpful is trying to change my
perspective to have much more of an
abundance mindset. Not feeling like I'm
wasting Claude's outputs by scrapping
what it comes up with. Because these
models are stochastic in nature, you get
varied outputs upon each poll or each
time you prompt it. That can be an issue
or you can use that in your favor by
running multiple of these at the same
time. In order to do that, what I
typically will do is I will use git work
trees. So in this case, I've got another
repository. If I go back here to Patrick
to the root, I've got a second one which
is two. And that is using a git work
tree which is a way to very easily set
up essentially a copy of your
repository. So you can create multiple
work trees and it's almost like you have
three separate versions of your
repository but it's all within one.git
folder in your main repo and each one
has its own branch. So in my case I've
got Patrick Ellis IO2. I could kick off
a cloud code in both of them and have
them both iterate on some front-end
changes and look at the two to kind of
AB contrast which one I think looks the
best and go from there. Typically, I'll
do this with like three different
prompts if I want to or the same prompt
but kicked off in three different work
trees in order to help get a variety of
outputs. One of my friends took this to
another level. it will actually kick off
three different processes running in
GitHub workers using headless cloud
codes that will come up with three
different outputs and then he'll use
another model another opus to judge
which of the three is the best. Another
thing that I find is really powerful
with these workflows is the ability to
package up these processes that our team
members use. So maybe we've got an
excellent designer or an excellent
engineering manager who's really good at
code review or back-end architect or
anything else. What's really neat is
being able to package up their expertise
into something like a sub agent or a
slash command or even an MCP and
distribute that across the team so that
you can benefit without even knowing the
nuances of the workflow from an expert
designer. When it comes to providing the
model's context in a prompt, I would
highly recommend also including as many
visual design elements as you can as
screenshots. So dragging in things like
even a lowfidelity sketch, kind of a UX
wireframe that you want, or references
to other designs, obviously a style
guide if you have it, or a collection of
different inspiration or kind of design
board elements that you want to bring
in. anything that you can use to channel
the visual modality of the model's
intellectual capacity in addition to all
the coding details such as being able to
specify front-end frameworks or best
practices. Things like hex codes for
colors and typography and everything
else. Those two combined are very
powerful. At the end of the day, the
performance of these models comes down
to context, tools, and validation steps.
So, I hope that this overview of the
tools and the validation side has been
really helpful and actionable for you.
Thank you so much for watching and stay
tuned for more videos like this. In the
meantime, if you enjoyed this video, I
think you'll really enjoy my recent deep
dive with my friends Anod and Galen at a
Seattle founders group on all of our
best practices for Claude Code. At least
all that we could fit into our
presentation. You can find that video
above along with my most recent video.